that reminds me of that time we went
with
the post sorry name drop mhm yeah yeah
yeah here you Dro you Dro this there you
go and we were playing beer pong and
same shoes by the
way yeah they're similar for sure
they're the same model no they're not
these are the 550s oh jeez those are the
can I take it back then
it what were we doing we were playing
you guys were playing beer pong I was
just observing and that one kid every
time he'd miss he kept going oh [__] my
ass who was that it was just some dude
who was there and then from that like
I've always wanted to do a sketch where
it just like keeps going
going by the end he's like God you're
all SL stuffing my mouth with your [__]
it's
like yeah I guess we are yeah that's
then they all start getting head from
him yeah
yeah anyways dude what happened this
weekend nothing yeah nothing honestly
parents were in town zil went for a
couple runs went for a couple hikes got
a couple
smoothies I did some Christmas baking
honestly just real domestic
[__] you know what' you
do I got to think about it oh by the way
our songs doing pretty well is it yeah
that's good we don't have to play it why
don't we run it actually no I'm kidding
I'm kidding why doesn't everyone run it
in their sleep as well let's get it to
number one man can't believe he did that
what Mr Bieber oh yeah everyone needs to
play the song in their sleep yeah and
that was the one about like eating
babies too wasn't it something like
tasty wasn't it about like eating kids
yeah pull up the lyrics of that yummy
yummy yeah yeah no it wasn't but like
the video was all kids remember I
thought it was that Banquet Hall thing
oh yeah yeah it was children what am I
thinking
of yeah yeah the lyric video I think
that's what it
was maybe search the lyric video or or
no it was his Instagram promo for it
search Just Bieber yummy Instagram promo
like he would just post pictures of
babies and it would say hash
yummy like what the [__] he kept it up
he kept it
up it was right in front of our eyes the
whole time look at that pizza gate you
monsters he's talking about adrenochrome
that's what the song's actually I was
going to say he's not he's not doing any
favors for the people that believe you
know that you know they're siphoning the
baby blood and eating the you know baby
forkin yeah look at how many times he
did it I didn't know that yeah wow I'm
late to
this this is a funny tweet leaves fans
confused after he posts 13 pictures of
seemingly random babies with the
captioned yummy on his
Instagram like why the
[__] this is
indefensible like there's not even a
single reason why you could sort of
surmise that would make this make sense
you can't walk it back from here you
just the only he's eating babies the
only thing he can say is I wanted to eat
them then everyone would be like oh I
guess yeah it kind of makes sense kind
of hard on his yeah kind of
sick then that would start the political
discourse I remember the whole eating
baby thing but I never knew where that
that came from yeah it's like Justin
Bieber eats
kids because of that cuz he he's pretty
he was the one that self-professed it
kind of what marketing genius was like
you should post the child I I don't
think anyone told him to do that I think
he was just kind of shooting from the
hip he's like I think I got a feeling in
my stomach this is going to be this is
right like this is really going to be
good promo and he didn't tell anyone he
just posted that and his PR hit him up
his PR like you know someone in the
office was like yo what the Justin just
posted this and they're like oh [__] I'm
picturing what is that his artist
mentality and his artist voice
going it's going to mess with people's
minds cuz the song is called yummy but
if you post a kid they're going to go
what do these things have to do with
each other and it's like
yeah rightfully so yeah yeah exactly he
goes
no it's
cool 13 of them too he he chose that
number on purpose man yeah he went hard
he gave him all the baffet I guess oh
yeah went to the forest was sitting
there with Bill Clinton yeah here you go
[Music]
mhm yeah You' think by the 10th one
people were like all right dude you
really got to stop doing this soon as PR
agent begging please please please
Justin has to stop posting the babies
please Justin put the phone down put the
phone nothing yummy about these babies
why are you scared I'm going to post a y
look at how many more I have look at how
many more I have saved to my to my photo
album how long were you searching babies
for do you think you went to those
people's houses and take a picture he's
like I we want to use your kid for a
marketing roll out they're like awesome
and he just walks in he's like
hey they're like what's up I'm going to
post it now yeah yeah that's so cool
Justin thank you so much
yummy he's in your living room yummy I
can't believe I can't believe that 13
times
yeah
bro wild I wonder how they tasted
JK yeah yeah maybe he actually ate them
maybe that was like I'm about to eat
this baby maybe there like people on
Instagram post their lunch right yeah
that no I was going to say that's we're
we're behind on this all like the pizza
gay people that's what they saw yeah
yeah they were like well duh yeah yeah
he's going to eat that [__] kid yeah
which he may have he may have eaten that
baby at that at that level of power
maybe he was he's posting it post eating
it yeah he's just kind of sitting there
like in that sort of like oh man [__]
that was good yummy got to let the
people know about this one this is going
to a place isn't it yep kind of dark so
anyways I girl you got that yummy
yeah sorry I just don't know what those
lyrics have to do with that with babies
yeah yeah and the kids in the video I
don't think there is kids in the video
is there no what we just see I was
thinking about his Instagram promo
play this oh that person just looks very
young
no I remember thinking for the
budget what the hell was this the pink
hair is
sick yeah unfortunately that's extremely
cool yeah we're going to look back on
this one and think man what a absolute
classic what are the lyrics
gr he kind of looks like Milly Bobby
Brown you know what's funny about music
videos if you just cut enough times in a
30se second period you can't really have
an opinion about it yeah it's well I
kind of like this
part no it's very true yeah I feel like
they used to do that way more they did
like it would be like every [__] half
second there's a cut so you never really
like feel good about watching it cuz
you're always like what wait wait that's
why 2000's music videos were fun they
were like
full stories
yeah